les scientifiques sont tous d'accord
pour dire que le sar skov 2 d'agents
virales responsables de deux lakovic 19
et transmis par voie aérosols c'est à
dire comme vous l'avez très bien dit
dans nos gouttelettes de respiration qui
peuvent s'accumuler planer comme ça dans
une pièce mal ventilée quand on est à
l'extérieur on les voit à ces
gouttelettes de respiration quand il
fait froid vous savez ce petit nuage qui
sort deux narines il se dilue dans
l'atmosphère immédiatement et donc il
n'y a aucun cas rapportés sur les plus
de 200 millions de cas y'a aucun cas
rapportés dans la littérature de
contamination de ce genre en revanche
les contaminations sont rapportés
totalement c'est à dire sauf petite
anecdote totalement dans des lieux clos
mal ventilée souvent bondées et
ses lieux qu'il faut sécuriser en fait
il ya eu très peu de recherches bien
contre bien construite pour montrer
l'efficacité de la ventilation sur le
contre le coc vide alors que dans
d'autres agents infectieux qui se
transmettent aussi par aérosol par
exemple le bacille de la tuberculose
il ya beaucoup de travaux très
démonstratif en particulier je voudrais
signaler un travail que j'ai bien aimé
qui a été publié vous savez en décembre
2010 knox juste avant le démarrage de
cette pandémie par une équipe taïwanaise
il investiguer une épidémie de
tuberculose
dans une université de taïwan ils se
sont rendus compte que les locaux
étaient pas vétuste mais ils ont voulu
faire des mesures de co2 parce que c'est
très difficile de savoir dans un local
cil et bien ventilé ou pas et ils ont vu
des taux de concentration de co2 très
élevé 3200 parties par million c'est
très élevé pour vous dire dans la rue
c'est 400 on s'attend à avoir un minimum
de 400 mails à 3200 donc ils se sont dit
ça ça doit être un lieu propice aux
contaminations on va tout faire pour
faire baisser et donc ils ont mis une
bonne aération ils ont ouvert les
fenêtres aux étages dans les sous sols
ils ont mis des purificateurs d'air
breizh quand est tombée à moins de 1000
tpm il y avait 95% de contamination en
moins et ils ont encore continuer au
dessous de 600 ppm on se rapproche
presque de la rue alors il ya zéro
contamination alors voilà on aimerait
des travaux comme ça pour que qu'ils
puissent appuyer les politiques
publiques mais en attendant si on veut
vraiment réduire la transmission mais
qui est contre la ventilation je vous
pose la question que l'on soit contre le
port du masque c'est dommage parce que
c'est très efficace mais ça gêne un peu
les gens qu'on soit contre les
confinements le télétravail de le toux
toutes les misères que l'on a pu subir
eh bien on peut le comprendre elles sont
liberticides vous parliez du pass
sanitaire c'est aussi un peu liberticide
on est tous d'accord avec cela mais la
ventilation qui est contre respirer un
air qui est un peu purifiée
[Musique]